Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So due to tornados and broken airplanes and
a chain of events too complicated for my exhausted
brain to unravel, I have visited airports
9 times in the past 100 hours and I am very
tired, and recently I unexpectedly found myself
alone on a train in New York, the city where
Brotherhood 2.0 began for me, and also the
city where earlier this year we played a sold
out show at Carnegie Hall, a dependent clause
that I will get tired of saying when never.
So anyway, there I was on the train blinking
a lot, because my eyes desperately wanted
to be closed, and I kept thinking about this
tumblr message I had received earlier, from
a middle school student, who is currently
attending the very same school that I attended
in 7th grade, and who has one of the same
teachers that I had.
The message read in part: Ms [name retracted]
and I were talking, and she told me that you
were a quiet, unique and miserable boy in
middle school. She also told me that you were
bullied because of your awesomeness.
It didn't feel like awesomeness at the time
of course, at the time, I was just miserable.
I mean Hank, you'll note that this teacher
didn't say I was a good student, because I
wasn't. I wasn't merely a nerd, I was, or
at least I felt like I was, a stupid nerd,
which is like the worst kind of combo. I take
that back, pizza combos are the worst kind
of combos, they are an insult to pizza.
But anyway, I almost never think about middle
school now Hank, but the message really forced
me to remember it, and also I was on a train,
which inherently makes you kind of nostalgic.
So yeah, it's true that I was miserable, and
that I was bullied. In fact, I would often
fantasise about hurting my bullies, or holding
a gun to their heads and making them apologise,
making them feel as scared and powerless as
I felt. But of course, that isn't the way
forward.
I realise now that the people who bullied
me were not evil, they were kids, living with
their own fear and pain, some of whom were
dealing with trauma and abuse that I never
even could of imagined. Now that doesn't justify
their behaviour, but it does help me to understand
that it really wasn't about me. Their treatment
of me was not a reflection of my value as
a human being, and while it was very difficult
for me to feel anything but miserable in those
days, in retrospect I survived middle school
because many people in fact were quite kind
to me. My parents, teachers, fellow nerds
and even popular strangers who wouldn't stand
for bullying.
We decide collectively what kind of behaviour
is acceptable, and while The Lord of the Flies
would have you believe that like adolescents
always descend into mere cruelty, my experience
of social orders has been much more complicated.
I've found that sometimes, often even, kids
are capable of tremendous kindness and generosity,
in fact that's been the hallmark of the nerdfighter
community for more than seven years now, and
I'm proud to be a nerdfighter in part because
I wish so much that I could have been one
in 7th grade. There are always nerdfighters
in Our Pants (link in the dooblydoo) who
will listen to you if you will also listen
back, and that is truly awesome.
Right so anyway Hank, there was this moment
onstage at Carnegie Hall, during the soundcheck,
when John Darnielle of the Mountain Goats
said into the mic: "this is a message for
sixteen year old me, not only did you survive,
you are playing piano at Carnegie Hall". Now
I'm not going to tell you that like everyone
who has a tough time as a kid ends up at Carnegie
Hall, but the idea that those years have to
be the best of your life is just ridiculous.
So to the young woman who wrote me, to myself,
stranded far from home in an endless string
of airports and train rides, I call up the
great Robert Frost quote: "The only way out
is through". You will get through. I will
get through.
Hank, I will see you, hopefully from Indianapolis,
on Friday.